Hillary Clinton's defeat in last year's
presidential race is one of the biggest
upsets in political history but while
her election night loss may have shocked
the world two journalists say signs
pointing to that very outcome were
hiding in plain sight they detail their
findings in the new book shattered
inside Hillary Clinton's doomed campaign
how's that for a title and we welcome
the authors Jonathan Alan and Amy parn
skies Congrats on the new book thank you
so there are a host of people across the
country that want to know what happened
one of the things that I took away from
the book was there were two axes inside
the camp the data and analytics team
driven by Robby Mook and this sort of
gut retail politics team largely held by
John Podesta and Bill Clinton John what
happened between those two factions well
we live in the society now where
everybody is so focused on data and we
have so much data and it's so important
to so many things that we do and there
were people inside the campaign that
just believed that you could slice and
dice the electorate and turn out the
right number of people in the right
number of places by by really playing
close to the edge and try to be as
efficient as possible and then there was
another set Bill Clinton was really a
leader of this set of the old-school
politicians who believed that you got to
go out and persuade people and change
minds and and that the data won't be
static if you change people's minds so
there was this big tension and we detail
this in the book it's one of the things
that people haven't talked about a whole
lot yet is this tremendous tension
between these two ideas the art of
politics the Bill Clinton the old school
bill tell politics and the data science
of it and both are important but this
campaign over relied on data you
describe this as a campaign that was
miserable even before it started which
is a pretty ominous statement but but
what struck me also is that what you say
is early on Hillary Clinton didn't
really have a reason for running you say
Hillary had been running for president
for almost a decade and diddles didn't
still really have a rationale yeah so we
detailed us in the book starting from
her speech on Roosevelt Island she
brought in a slew of advisors to help
her kind of form her message to have
like a central core that she was driving
she never quite had that center of
gravity she there she brought in an
Obama
speechwriter to help her and even he
threw up his hands and left and was like
I can't do anything about this he was
used to just working with President
Obama he and the president and he
thought it was just too out of hand that
there were too many people too many
cooks in the kitchen the normally
unflappable Jon Favreau that free-trader
talking about there was also a
systematic under estimating of critical
moments in the campaign right the emails
for example a me Hillary Clinton didn't
want to apologize and really take that
on headfirst in the way that a lot of
her staff seemed to think that she
needed to and there was a moment of
tension that we detail in the book where
she's like she and the president are
kind of frustrated about why their
message isn't resonating and they kind
of take it out on their aides they're
like come on get it together we you know
they don't quite realize what's
happening that the email has sort of you
know become the campaign so they're
trying to push back and her aides are
kind of getting her to a place where she
can feel comfortable and actually talk
about email and that's the point of
tension and this is like the first
summer where she had just launched her
speech she can't get her message across
because it's all about email yeah did
she did she misunderstand the mood of
the country absolutely in fact there are
several places in the book where you
sort of get a window into that one in
particular after New Hampshire where she
got crushed by Bernie Sanders 22 points
she's flying on a plane with one of her
closest friends mignon Moore who had
been brought in basically to listen to
her you know I mean she's she's in this
sort of devastated place and many young
more gets on the plane with her and
Clinton says to minyan you know I don't
understand what's going on in the
country I can't get my arms around it
and we see this throughout the campaign
that there are moments where she could
be more populist to tap into this
populist fire that Bernie Sanders was
igniting that Donald Trump wasn't
uniting and she just it was in that
Matoo who she is she's somebody who
really believes in change through the
system you get into the system and you
work from the inside to change it and
what was going on in the country was a
real desire to break down that system
you guys get into the excruciating
moments of election night 2016 which was
one of the line in the sand as far as
American politics is concerned in terms
a disjunctive moment what happened
inside Clinton headquarters so they find
out and there are four kind of centers
of where they're gathered a couple in
from one in Brooklyn there's a war room
going on here in Midtown in her hotel
room at the Peninsula Hotel her aides
are gathered around her they see what's
happening in Florida it's not good
they're getting results back
she is very stoic the entire time
finally the President President Obama is
actually trying to get her to concede
the message is a very clear message is
that he calls and says that his
political adviser David Simas calls and
basically is trying to push she concedes
and then there's a moment where she
actually has to make that call and and
say I'm sorry Donald something she had
never a Donald right gradually gradually
Donald and then yes and then it's this
moment and then she has to apologize she
gets a call from the president it's a
consolation call and she has to say I'm
sorry mr. president so it's it's quite
an evening for her she she is feeling
the weight of the moment she has let
down her party the nation the president
and his legacy it's you can feel the
unthinkable moment for the Clinton
campaign yeah an unthinkable moment
after ten years of running for president
and and I think it's one of the more
powerful moments in history and
certainly in the book and that tick-tock
is the first one that anybody's seen
from behind the scenes a lot of great
tick-tock as they say yes solid read
guys the book is shattered inside
Hillary Clinton's doomed campaign
Jonathan Allen Amy Parnes thank you both
for being with us this morning thank you
so much